thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
they can have visions of the future or
seeded it and sometimes be uniquely
susceptible to invasion by an entity
that is alien today objection
finally geez on what grounds how about
silliness Your Honor no silliness is not
a valid objection objective relevance or
object to improper opinion silliness is
not in the Federal Rules of Evidence hey
legal eagles it's time to think like a
lawyer and today in a special Halloween
episode we are covering the Exorcism of
Emily Rose now I'd like to apologize
ahead of time having some technical
difficulties here in my office and I
didn't get a whole lot of sleep last
night I woke up at 3 o'clock in the
morning it couldn't get back to sleep
and yeah so so anyway be sure to comment
in the form of an objection which I will
either sustain or overrule and stick
around until the end of the video where
i give the Exorcism of Emily Rose a
grade for legal realism so yes without
further ado let's dig into the exorcism
of emily rose so apparently this movie
is based on a real-life story where a
woman who suffered from severe epilepsy
had her family call in a priest who
administered an exorcism on her
believing that she was possessed by
demons or ghosts or something and during
the course of the exorcism she died
potentially of neglect potentially of
abuse the priest was then put on trial
and this trial is sort of a mishmash of
the things happening at the criminal
trial for negligent homicide as well as
what may or may not have happened
depending on who you talk to during the
course of this supposed exorcism in the
case before you the evidence will show
that the victim had a serious medical
condition oh wow man did medical
treatment we will prove that the victims
condition rendered her physically and
psychologically incapable
of caring for herself Wow so there's a
lot of stuff going on in the
prosecution's opening statement that is
just it's perfectly realistic in a way
that you rarely ever see in movies in
television first the prosecutor is
standing at the lectern which was set up
specifically for the arguments to the
jury he's using notes often we get this
idea that lawyers should be talking
extemporaneously and yelling in front of
the jury when really it's more likely to
be like this he's just telling the facts
and in fact the specific wording that he
used is the facts will show or we will
approve an opening statement is not
argument you're just showing the jury or
you're telling the jury what you think
the facts are going to show in the
future and you know the tone that he's
using is Right - this is a somber
occasion this is not the time for
yelling you're not going to put yourself
out on a limb you're just gonna talk
about the dry facts that are going to be
elicited in a persuasive way so this
actually might be the most realistic
portrayal of a district attorneys
opening statement I have ever seen in a
movie it's it's amazing this is what she
looked like before the defendant began
his religious treatment this is a
photograph taken of her on the day that
she died this is also pretty realistic
as well there's no reason to you know
pound on the table and yell and scream
when you have just a very very powerful
visual image and so a real-life
prosecutor would absolutely want to use
the strength of that particular evidence
without trying to beat the jury over the
head with it I've known Emily her entire
life I took care of all of the Rose
girls can you describe Emily as you knew
her growing up okay so this is a I guess
a family physician this could be a
really tricky witness because on the one
hand they're a medical professional but
on the other hand they're lay witness
they've seen the the in in this case the
victim so they have first-hand knowledge
and it's a question of whether you're
calling this person as an
spirt witness or are you calling them as
a percipient lay witness you can get
into a little bit of trouble when you go
past the percipient witness and to
asking them to apply and based on their
medical testimony let's see what happens
here
as if it's sickly in her early years she
stayed inside a lot reading learning
music how did she feel about going away
to school objection speculation the
witness is not a psychiatrist well I
mean even if the witness was a
psychiatrist there's no way that she can
know the internal mental state of the
victim you can find out about what they
said or how they manifested themselves
which might lead to an inference of what
they felt but you can't ask the actual
question how did someone feel or what
did someone think that's totally
improper dr. Muller what's your position
at the University Hospital I am chairman
of the Department of Neurology and after
you heard about the dorm-room incident
what were your initial thoughts oh boy
so for an expert witness especially a
doctor you would spend a really really
long time building up their bona fides
and their credibility and their past CV
their accolades their education you
wouldn't just say what's your position
at this hospital and then dig into their
expert opinion you've got to lay the
foundation that number one this person
is qualified to give testimony in court
so you satisfy the judge but also you
want the jury to actually believe this
person so you want to build them up so
that they believe your expert instead of
the defense's expert so both for legal
reasons and for sort of persuasive
reasons you really have to spend a lot
of time building up your experts not
like this
so suspecting that Emily was epileptic
how did you proceed I administered an
electroencephalograph what did the EEG
reveal it showed a possible epileptic
focus and the patient's left temporal
lobe did this require specific treatment
yes I began a medication schedule for
Emily with the drug gambutrol I also
advise regular follow-up examinations
and further tests but Emily failed to
keep her follow-up the partners with me
did she give any reason for
discontinuing these appointments yes she
told me she was convinced that her
condition was a spiritual one okay here
you have some really interesting
testimony that I think most people would
misconstrue most people hear an
out-of-court statement this
doctor is saying that Emily Rose said
this well Emily Rose is not the one who
is testifying and in fact Emily Rose is
also conveying the things that her
priest told her as well all of these
things would normally seem like hearsay
they are out of court statements that's
absolutely true and we can't
cross-examine necessarily these
particular witnesses however I don't
think this is actually hearsay because
here say has to be an out-of-court
statement used for the truth of matter
asserted the truth of the matter
asserted is that Emily Rose was feeling
some sort of spiritual encounter whether
or not that is true is not the point of
the statement being used the point of
the statement is to explain why Emily
did not go back to this doctor and
receive more medical treatment and the
point of the statement is to show why
Emily Rose went to her priest instead of
going back to a doctor so whether or not
she was actually having a spiritual
encounter is irrelevant the point of the
statement is to explain the actions of
both the victim and the actions of the
defendant in this case so I think that
under these circumstances it actually
doesn't meet the legal definition of
here safe did you ask Emily why she had
stopped filling her gambutrol
prescriptions yes she said that father
Moore had suggested she stop taking the
drug and what in your medical opinion
was the direct result of father Moore's
suggestion I firmly believe that father
Moore's suggestion killed her outrageous
conclusions based on pure hearsay
evidence technically correct but I'll
allow it as part of his expert opinion
testimony oh boy that was the wrong
objection the problem is not an expert
relying on hearsay experts are allowed
to rely on hearsay experts are allowed
to rely on otherwise inadmissible
testimony to form their expert
conclusions
however this witness probably doesn't
have the expertise to be able to testify
to the cause of death
and this witness certainly doesn't have
the expertise to be able to talk about
the legal causation here which is even
separate potentially from the the
medical reasoning for why Emily Rose
died so that was totally improper
testimony the defense lawyer was right
to object but the defense lawyer made
the wrong objection
and as a result was it was overruled mr.
Thomas has contended that Emily Rose
suffered from a serious medical
condition that required medical
treatment nothing more he has asserted
that any attempt by my client to help
Emily by anything other than medical
means was not only inappropriate but
criminally negligent well yeah
generally helping people with health
conditions involves actually using
medical means so that is a reasonable
standard for a prosecution to put out
there Emily roses condition in fact was
demonic possession an exorcism was her
only hope for a cure some of you may
find yourself unable to reconcile
Emily's beliefs or those of the
defendant with your own you may not
believe demons exist you won't have to
because you will see that after the
utter failure of the doctors to help
Emily father more simply tried to help
Emily in a different way using an
approach that he Emily and her family
firmly believed was her only chance for
relief yeah I don't actually think a
judge would let that come in
I mean effectively you could argue that
the mental state of the defendant is
relevant that he legitimately believed
that the victim was in some sort of
demonic possession but the thing is the
court is not going to recognize the
existence of demons and in reality I
think what would happen is that the
judge would call a sidebar she would
specifically tell the attorney that
she's not allowed to make the argument
that the demons were actually
responsible here and if the lawyer
insisted on doing it then they would get
in the instruction at the end that says
the jury absolutely cannot make that a
basis for their particular decision it's
a weird situation where did you receive
your education as he ate and then at
Cambridge and what is your specific area
of expertise I studied these spiritual
experiences of people in various
cultures and the physiological and
psychological changes they undergo
during these experiences would it be
accurate to say that you specialize in
the scientific study of possession yes
possession is one term for a basic human
experience reported by a great number of
people all around the world in my
fieldwork I've seen many people who
experienced a sense of being invaded by
an entity from the supernatural realm
okay
so despite the qualifications of this
supposed expert there are many reasons
why this testimony doesn't come in
number one I think it's an improper
expert opinion I mean there is certain
scientific rigor that is required to be
able to testify as an expert in court
and number two it's more prejudicial
than it is probative it's more likely to
cause confusion and unfair prejudice
than it is to actually clarify anything
here this sounds like total nonsense to
me
I believe that Emily Rose was a
hypersensitive a person with an unusual
connection to what Carlos Castaneda
called the separate reality
hypersensitive are born different from
everyone else yeah at this point the
prosecution should really be objecting
to relevance even if the judge lets it
in you need to preserve these kind of
things for appeal because this is a
total nonsense argument they can have
visions of the future or ceded it and
sometimes be uniquely susceptible to
invasion by an entity that is alien to
the objection finally geez on what
grounds how about silliness your honor
no silliness is not a valid objection
objective relevance or object to
improper opinion silliness is not in the
Federal Rules of Evidence how do you
know him
well no he was his parishioner at st.
Vincent's Church about 15 years ago I
hadn't seen the heard of him for years
when he called me last fall he needed
help so what kind of help doctor
he wanted a medical perspective from a
psychiatrist you know what want one that
he knew trusted to observe Emily's
physical and mental state so this would
be incredibly important evidence to put
forward to say that the priest called a
medical professionals to supervise
everything to make sure that from a
medical perspective that the the
exorcism didn't endanger the the patient
and that she was taken care of during
this time being able to say that you
called the doctor in to supervise
everything would probably be the most
important evidence you could possibly
put on in support of the defendant here
you would not want to wait for that
before he was arrested furthermore sent
this to me asked me to take care of it
No now remember audio recordings can be
hearsay if you are recording another
person you are probably recording
hearsay and the tape itself is also
considered hearsay it's a common
misconception that things like
videotapes or audio tapes or even
written documents themselves are just
per se admissible but on the contrary
most of the time those things are
considered hearsay and you have to have
a specific exception to the hearsay rule
in order to get those things in but you
also have a chain of custody and
authentication issue here to make sure
that this tape has not been tampered
with and it is what it purports to be so
you could have a really hard time
bringing in things like audio tapes into
court sometimes father Moore before you
could actually perform the exorcism you
had to get the sanction of the church
correct yes on October the 27th last
year I presented my assessment and
recommendations to the archbishop and he
authorized the exorcism that day before
I left the office so contrary to what
you see in movies and on TV having the
defendant testify in court is actually
very very rare mainly because people are
really afraid of what might come out on
cross-examination and frankly the
testimony of the accused is probably not
going to be particularly helpful
you make of this gesture this nod in
your direction what I don't know some
kind of that's not relevant I guess that
the game is on it is totally improper
for the prosecutor to be questioning the
defendant right now assuming we saw
everything that we were gonna see from
the defense it's crazy that they didn't
actually ask about the exorcism itself
you are sometimes allowed to ask new
questions of your witness it's called
redirect which happens after
cross-examination but the redirect is
only limited to what is brought up in
cross-examination and once you redirect
then again the prosecutor can recross
but that recross is limited to whatever
was brought up during the redirect so
it's crazy malpractice that they put
this guy on the stand made him subject
to whatever cross-examination is
happening here
but they didn't ask about the crucial
thing that they wanted to talk about
here so this night when you began to
prepare Emily's exorcism was it your
first encounter with this demon ghost
yes have you seen it again I've seen it
ever since
no further questions at this time
there's so many more questions that you
would ask a cross-examination redirect
your honor father Moore
okay after you receive the Bishop's
authorization when did you proceed with
an exorcism October 31st on Halloween is
that a bit dramatic the Halloween
tradition is based on legends throughout
history that indicate a real increase in
spiritual activity on that night and I
thought we could use the occasion to
draw them into the open yeah okay so
this is totally improper for redirect
because these are questions that you
would ask on the original direct
examination so you don't get a second
bite at the Apple to go in to redirect
into these subjects that you didn't
bring out the first time I offer into
evidence this cassette recorder and
audiotape as defense judgments a and
people were not made aware of the
existence of this tape until lately I
don't we your honor this tape is new
evidence that just came into our
possession yesterday evening we have
provided counsel for the people with the
transcript of its contents you mean this
tape was not given to you by your client
no your honor we received it from a
reluctant witness dr. Graham Cartwright
who will also be called to testify to
its authenticity Your Honor the people
will find his name on the updated
witness list we provided to them this
morning yeah okay so there are a couple
big problems here judges hate being
blindsided and presumably there have
been months since the start of this
particular trial the odds of this if
this evidence being authentic are pretty
slim and to not call the person who
provided the audio tape and when it's
not the defendant those are just huge
red flags that this is inauthentic it's
something that's fake it didn't come
from the defendant who allegedly made it
their chain of custody problems it's
being sprung on the the prosecution in
the middle of trial I think all of this
means that the judge would probably not
allow this audio tape to come in is the
defense ready to proceed yes your honor
the defense recalls father Richard Moore
yeah you don't get to just recall a
witness whenever you feel like it
this defense attorneys getting three
bites at the Apple they called the
defendant once then they didn't ask all
the questions that they should have and
then they called the defendant again to
do a redirect examination
into topics that were not proper at all
to talk about because they didn't bring
him up the first time then that witness
was excused and they brought the witness
back again
to testify for a third time I mean this
is the kind of thing that judges
referred to as a circus and all of this
would be improper when did you last see
Emily alive the night before she died
her mother Maria called me and said that
Emily had asked me why did she ask to
see you why didn't you ask him about
this the first time around man to give
me this did Emily explained to you the
letter significance yes
she said she'd written it the morning
after the failed exorcism one that that
it was important for me to share mmm so
apparently the victim wrote a letter to
the defendant before she died this feels
like there's some major hearsay problems
here but let me think about this
I guess conceivably it doesn't really
matter necessarily about the truth of
what's in the letter
but I guess it can go to the state of
mind of the priest in terms of the
actions that he took or the actions that
he didn't take yeah arguably you're not
using the truth of the matter asserted
but you're using it for the effect on
the listener and the effect on the
mental state of the the victim in this
case I think maybe that letter does come
in as non hearsay because it's not being
used for the truth of the matter
asserted please read the verdict out
loud in my experience most times the
judges don't make the foreman actually
read the verdict because that's a lot of
pressure to put on one person so usually
the judge reads the verdict of the the
jury and they don't put the poor
foreperson on the spotlight like this
but you know it's dramatic so it's not
surprising you see it like this
in the case of the people versus father
Richard Moore we the jury find the
defendant guilty of negligent homicide
makes sense the court thanks the jury
for its service sentencing for this case
will be set for April 3rd that's also
good you don't see that often in movies
usually the sentencing is right away but
sentencing is almost always at a later
time
after some briefing to make sure that
they get the sentencings right because
sentencing is totally separate from
whether they establish guilt or not
generally speaking your honor if it
pleases the court
father Moore requested at the start of
trial that if found guilty he would be
sentenced immediately so what it doesn't
matter what he requests does the
prosecution have any objection to
expedited sentencing they should very
well sentencing is a complicated thing
in many states and the federal system
have complicated calculations that you
have to go through to make sure that the
the sentence fits the crime and you
don't want wild discrepancies between
people who have committed exactly the
same crime
are there any statements you would like
to make before I impose this sentence no
your honor very well excuse me your
honor but the jury would like to make a
recommendation regarding this objection
yeah it's totally improper sit down
counselor it's only a recommendation and
I would like to hear it yeah still we
recommend a sentence of time served
yeah that is not correct
I'll accept that all right that is the
exorcism of emily rose and now it's time
to give it a grade for legal realism on
the one hand you have some aspects of
the trial that were totally
spot-on the prosecutor was using the
lectern they were making pretty
reasonable arguments there weren't a
whole lot of history Onex going on
people weren't yelling and shouting and
saying you can't handle the truth
so the way that this homicide trial was
handled was actually very very realistic
on the other hand you have the admission
of a whole bunch of totally improper
evidence improper expert opinions and
they completely mangled the way that you
would actually have the examination of a
defendant's being recalled three or four
times in the trial so although I give
the Exorcism of Emily Rose a solid B not
bad but I really like to exercise some
of the demons some of the legal demons
[Laughter]
now there's no such thing as ghosts but
getting a suit that doesn't fit right
will haunt you for the rest of your life
if you're looking for a custom slim cut
suit that is shockingly affordable I
can't recommend endo Chino highly enough
all of my suits are now made by
Indochina including this blue two button
that I'm wearing right now it was custom
made just for me see the secret to a
great suit is all about the fit I'm a
reasonably athletic guy and I can never
buy suits off the rack because they just
simply never fit right I've actually
spent more than the cost of an Indo
Chino suit trying to get a tailor to fix
an off-the-rack suit before but with
Indo Chino you can send in your
measurements online or you can go to one
of their stores in person to have a
stylist take your measurements for me I
made an appointment I went to the store
in person and had a stylist work with me
for over 90 minutes when I went in for
the first time my personal stylist took
my measurements and a couple weeks later
I got the best fitting suit of my entire
life it was perfect right out of the box
and if it hadn't been perfect their
tailors would have fixed it for me at no
cost in no chena will make you a fully
custom suit tailored specifically for
you for less than $400 and
part is they still use the best
materials like super 140s wool I will
never get an off-the-rack suit again and
once you try it neither will you legal
eagles can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just three hundred and fifty
nine dollars when you enter the promo
code legal eagle at checkout or use the
link in the description
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel that's Indo Chino com promo
code legal eagle for the best custom
suit of your entire life so do you agree
with my grade leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
of all my other real lawyer reactions
over here where I will see you in court